今日は初日シャツをです今日はちょっとね1回
落ち着いて美容法の動画をプロと思います美しい皆さんきれい年退団し今日ば体の
ムダ毛どうしてますか
まあ女の子は気になりますよ男の子もねひょっとしたらその気を気にしてる人もいるか
もしれない僕はね駅がもぞもぞしてると嫌なんですよね1回僕の興味ラストやっぱね
ちょっとはい
てるんですよね気が入ってるわけですよ僕の体にもすげーもね入ってますちょっとこれ
からどんどん後あったかくなってきてはぁの露出をすることが多くな非常にやばいこれ
は何を意味するかというとそうムダ毛処理をしなきゃいけない冒険が独自に開発した
前進座都合の鹿の皆さんにご紹介しようと思いますこれをすればも毛深いそこの君も分
だけな線
ですよ
ん
ところ産品とってんだと指で今回はもう極秘ですまだ誰にも言ってないから今日は特別
に皆に全身脱毛の仕方を教えてあげるで愛子
用意するものはこちら一瞬でもう公達もするつべ仲間ちょっというわけでムダ毛を除毛
するシートがありますまあ普通に体に貼って剥がせば家が取れるって事なんですけども
考案のぺたぺたぺたぺたやってでも時間がかかってしまう
p やー読むところペペコ時間にかかってしまう
そこで私は考えそれ一つに40回も入っています今回5個準備したね200回分あり
ますいませんだっけこれ
ガッツじゃあなにこれこれもって結構怖いなぁあるほどいいだろ受け継いだと
ばてなんだこれだけ色おかしくねこんなに応えたなぁんね答え者があるんだけどこれ何
おかしくねっ
まいっかでこれ行うとりあえず体も全車にあるんですけどもそれで一番つ入って
とっても時間がもったいないので強力な洗濯バサミを準備しましたこの洗濯バサミを
ヒントにつけてそれにひもを通して下の先を飛ぶが固定できればスペックをプレグって
巻いてそれに僕が
うんって引っ張れば必ずの二つ星動画プンって取れるはずですそうすれば僕の身体向け
は減額
ありますこの一発で所一瞬で全部脱毛できますではまずはにしてにばための誹謗準備し
ます
ああああああ
めちゃくちゃピザ粉絲美ッ
ふーん
はい tv 出口全部できました約30分かかりましたね
これぞれにゃうとエッこちらのドアノブ根本から阿蘇てる部分になりますこの固定部分
にハンガーを全部擦りつけていきましょう
気持ちでいきました全部創作完了です
ここまで来るのに約1時間普通に行ったほうが全然配備でここから僕の体に実際これを
張っていきますどんな感じなんだろうガムテープで絶対強いんですよ
薄着怖いんだけどマジかーめっちゃめっちゃ接着力あっ色味を揃えて歌っいやあああ
こりゃブーバー今やべぇ
これはんじゃあ死にますよ
うよ見で猫全部抜きましょうどうせらんでぶー配布できましたひとまず跳ねそう心から
たちにあったので腕今からその教官が洗濯バサミを髪につけていきますガードこれ
大丈夫なのかな心臓 j んでしょ
catch catch catch catch catch
演芸ホールキャッチ多いや情景女長兼フィギュア
器具全部協力や洗濯は何が高ぶってる夫婦
me
敵ん
これで綺麗に脱毛できればいいんですよね
いいんじゃないゾンビ感染しまーさーんじゃ1間ってヤバイ
いやーやっぱ衝撃の痛さを感じたこれが俺の初めした
全身立つの一瞬で考える気を付けてる奴もできます
法律あるいやお姉さんはいいけどさ俺も一緒に
目立つみたい
できます抹茶あやばいマジじゃないかじゃないでしょ
らんやろやろデメテルよやれる
全身の毛はサーバー
トゥ
わー
ああああああ
チェック
します
いいあああああああっはあっは
うわぁ
大臣と